[Music]
hi everybody
nice to see you here so you may have
seen Ryan introduce denno in the dress
computer last year and this morning
Ashley gave us a great introduction to
cloud fair workers
it is exciting times once again like for
innovations in searcy Java runtimes so
here I am going to talk about our recent
effort to bring a new set of
api's into your core this may be an
opportunity for us to rethink about the
JavaScript API surface in the ecosystem
and create a more universal developer
experience across the of different
platforms so let's finish the boring
part real quick
allow me to introduce myself my name is
Joey
I live in Hangzhou I work remotely on
the comparison gaya I'm also a member of
the no technical steering committee if
you find me on github or Twitter
viajando Georgia so some of you may be
aware of this effort of bringing more
with api's into no core but maybe some
folks here are just curious because the
heroes here sings interesting so in case
I am using something goes that only a
very few people understood so what does
it mean when we talk about bringing web
api's into no core well we're basically
talking about adding browser api's to
the node.js runtime as building so that
you can Brunton on the server side
without using MP install so in this talk
I will try to be objective and summarize
how far we have come in this journey
where we are and we are going on a teeny
tiny sign note that J is part of node a
node a J's is silent
like many others I will try to use the
correct pronunciation in this talk so
here is a mental picture of how John
Smith in WoW came to be so in beginning
before Neil came along there were two
kinds of api's that came with the
runtime for JavaScript developers there
were some top-secret buildings like date
regulations errors that were part of
language a standardized by tc39 and
implemented by Joseph engines there was
a host api's and at that time hosts were
basically just browsers
these guys were implemented by the
browsers and are more or less than the
dyes by organizations like C or what wig
and then no was created and started to
take off on the server side initially
included some of the weather guys that
were already present in the browsers or
like at least some guys that look like
what you'll find in browsers but no also
introduced several different API is for
doing certain things on the server side
like even emitter instead of even target
in the browser's because the semantics
of the equivalent ap is on the browser
side may not happen in a sense for
servers like for example there isn't one
Dom tree in this execution contacts for
events bubble through on the server side
so it doesn't really make sense to
implement part of the even target
specification in node so as time goes by
browsers have developed and standardized
more api's in the browser to empower web
developers while now also developed
several
equivalent api's on the server side with
a different design because of the
popularity of the node.js runtime this
homegrown API is gradually became the de
facto standards for suicide just rerun
times but like obviously no one likes to
remember two sets of API is for doing
basically the same
so over the past few years people have
been sending feature requests you know
to bring the to platform closer together
for now it usually means making the
runtime more compatible with browsers so
no devaluate an implementation of the
requests and it is still looking into
more api's from the web so we currently
have different types of web api is
movement it in no core so something are
more look-alikes of the browser ones for
instance we have methods like set a mile
from the browser's and this is the
living standard of the timers in the one
wake at the mouth specification you know
we also have a similar set of timer
ideas but the implementation does not
strictly follow what the browser's do
for example settimana
returns an object while browsers usually
return a number instead the other type
of weather guys we have in no core are
the ones implemented with an existing
specification in mind and behave mostly
the same as the API is that you find in
browsers for instance the new URL
specifically invitation in no core was
developed specifically according to the
awake URL standard this means we did
look at the spec test when we
implemented them and we also have tests
so how do we know how close our
invitations are to the ones in the
browser we run a subset of the web
platform tests which are tests which
shared among browsers and other
informations so to see the current
status of web performs has confirmes
node you can look at the status files
under test the PT status folder of the
know project there are a few pretty
self-explanatory JSON files documenting
the performance of web standards
implemented in No so this one is
technique
not taking a web edition I won't mention
that there is now another type of web
standards implemented in the core we
have collaborated with the what wake the
HTML specification and the first
imitation of Jason modules has landed in
the master branch as part of our
experimental Akuma script module order
so ya know implemented first so here we
have the web advise a momenta dinner
core that can be alternatives to certain
moon grounded buildings the legacy
methods under the URL and Kure string
building module can be replaced by the
new URL and URL such parents classes and
certain encoding and decoding methods of
buffer and string decoder can be
replaced by text encoder and text
decoder as well and there is the
performance high length API which for
example can be used to replace certain
tiny methods in the process object in
addition we also have sun api's there
are not exactly replacements for
existing node api's but are similar
enough in many use cases that it is
reasonable to consider them as
alternatives be sure to read the
documentation if you want to rewrite
your code with a sake ice
for example Q micro tasks can be used to
cure micro tasks that will be run
asynchronously which can be used to
replace process the next stick if you
have if you do not have strict
requirement about timing one judge has
to be run
there is also web worker which spawns
threads in node and it may be used to
replace child processes if you are only
looking for a way to upload your
competition to our recipe of course and
you don't necessarily need processes so
as of no 12
we have several web api ignitions that
are now stable and can be used in
production those are listed on the left
here
and these are available as gobos so you
don't have to require a building to get
hold of them these are also covered by
the web platforms has in your court
there may be some additional extensions
in the city is and some minor has
specified behavior differences but at
least those are fairly limited and we
are aware of them we also have a few
api's that are still experimental which
means there may still be breaking
changes in the future these are
currently placed under building modules
and not on the global object yet the
current experimental experimental web
api is that we have our workers and
performance time in MPI but they also
differ significantly from what you would
get from the powders and we do not run
web platform tests for them yet so watch
out so there is also an imputation of
webassembly the java api of represent
lee that would get free get for free
from v8l but although the web api of it
is has not been imminent yet other than
existing API is there are a bunch of
others that are hunting the issue
tracker oops there are still under
active discussion there are web strings
which are the foundation of many web
services like vacations but then we
already have no strings in core which
are also the foundation of many existing
no core api's in case you didn't know
there are many different types of
strings note their string number one
which have several issues so they now
introduce string number two but any also
has some issues and then known to this
terminal 3 which still has issues so
there is now an irritation of strings
called Bob which is under development
for some time and we hopefully solve our
all our problems anyway this is not a
string
talk you can read the documentation if
you want to learn more about him so with
all the strings you can imagine how
complicated it will be to bring yet
another string into no core and there is
also fetch which is probably the most
requested Web API in no core we just had
a session about it this week at the open
J's cover summit in Berlin and there is
now a new working progress pull request
into how to bring it fetch and you know
Court so we have talked about the
history of this Web API is in node and
one way coming next so why exactly are
we doing this one obvious reason is when
a common API surface there is less
cognitive burden for developers we could
share documentation tutorials tooling
instead of developing and maintaining a
separate set of educational resources
this is especially important for just
straight beginners at the moment they
have to choose between Web API is and
node API is when they are just getting
started with a common API surface
beginners can be less distracted when
they're just learning about basics there
are still differences between the two
platform but it will be less
intimidating when they already learned a
bit more about these api's so another
reason for adding the Web API is
internal core is that we simply have
more maintenance compared to most NPM
modules
this is officers and it's natural that
contributors come and go you know even
when the existing main trainers of a
specific building module show up less
often we have an open governance and an
effective nomination em onboarding
process to bring new contributors into
the team
compared to regular NPM modules this
kind of maintenance story fits better
with the web guys that are designed as
buildings for the host environment so if
you have been paying some attention to
this topic you may be aware that it
takes an extraordinary amount of time
for these api additions to actually be
accepted into no core so here I will lay
out some of the reason why there are
several requests that keep showing up in
the issue checker but I have never
really gone anywhere so everything I'm
going to talk about later are in the
context of the consensus seeking model
of no core so no core is operated under
the consensus from over 100 Cork
libraries these are contributors who
have write access to the repository for
every technical decision any one of
these 100 more than 100 no collaborators
who raise an objection if consensus
cannot be reached within the
collaborators it may come down to a vote
among the members of the technicals
during committee who are a subset of the
collaborators but we usually try to
avoid voting we also take community
feedback into account even if it's not
from someone who have committed into no
before so here are the come arguments
against adding what a key is internal
core there is still to some extent a
small core philosophy within old core
it's about providing only the basic
functionalities in core and empower
users to implement user land modules
instead of building our own opinionated
api's that may become compatibility or
maintenance burden this philosophy has
been broken several times in past but at
least far as web api goes we are still
mostly just trying to expose the
existing functionalities through a
different guys services this
is not exactly and on the tear that's
welcomed by everybody either especially
when the web api may also lack features
that do not make sense for browsers oh
yeah and like sometimes they may be
necessary for servers so one alternative
to adding this API is in node is to
release them as official modules
theoretically for modules that are
maintained under the node organization
it will be possible to have a
maintenance story similar to the one
that no court has but some may also
argue that it is easier to optimize an
invasion
if it's done in court because it can use
certain internal api's or sometimes it
may just not be technically possible to
implement something without access to
internals apart from the philosophical
concerns there are also concerns about
the design of the web api is because
there are more than just a bunch of
interfaces behind the design of these
api's there is just a very different
context for instance the browser has a
very different security model when you
fetch an API endpoint for example at
Bartek on for a script living in photo
come and you want to send credentials
like cookies along with the request
fetch as implemented according to the
specifications should follow the
cross-origin resource sharing protocol
and check the access control allow
urging header in the HTTP response
before invoking the callbacks where the
data so that untrusted scripts cannot
steal your cookies when your server is
not aware of them so somewhere in node
there isn't really a concept of origins
at least for now so this square roots
are loaded from your local file system
and are just trusted by default within
current security models now
if you perform the request using the
existing at the beta request method in
node this security policy would have to
be implemented by the users well if they
do want them it is not impossible to
implement something like this node but
this may just be confusing for most
users because then we all have two
conflicting security models you know so
when we look at the fetched
specification the interface itself is
just the tip of the iceberg
there are many implications under the
surface of the java api like cross
origin resource training content
security policy caching interrupts with
service workers and like potential
management so some of this may make
sense for now some of them don't if we
only implement part of the API that we
think make sense for node we make her
fills our users more because this will
bring another kind of platform
compatibility headache to everyone there
is also another type of concerns
ecosystem has already come to depend on
a lot of existing image structure in
node and this may differ significantly
from their web in Creveling for example
we have different interfaces to do
streaming and to emit events as usual
there are even more differences in the
underlying design of these
infrastructures when implementing web
applies node we also need to decide
whether we want to introduce the web
infrastructure internal core or base the
higher-level API is on the existing node
infrastructure or just use some
construction layer instead we will also
need to figure out the interrupt
between these abstractions for other
existing modules and this work just
takes a lot of time so there are a lot
of open questions to answer of the a lot
of decisions to be made and
this you know just some in the current
consensus city motto in no core but how
do new web api actually added up being
added to no cordis days usually starts
with a feature request opened in the
node.js slash node repository to
actually make progress on the request
someone or some group of people need to
set up step up and start a prototype
immunization they do not need to be no
collaborators it could be anyone who are
willing to invest their time in their
work typically they will create for it
either as a personal work or as a fork
under the node organization and they
were hacked together a initial
invitation then send a pull request back
to the main repository against the
master branch at this stages terribly
objections coming from collaborators or
the community sometimes the proposal
just gets stalled and closed for example
this is the current status of the
feature request for web crypto sometimes
but really there are no jobs there are
no objections or these objections gets
resolved either through discussion or
through voting either way someone must
be interested enough in this feature to
get it through the consensus seeking
model then the initial invitation make
it merged into the master branch
so once the feature is merged in master
will start iterating on this fixing bugs
optimizing the mission at a certain
point depending on how feasible it is we
may start incorporating the sub set of
web platform tests for it and
collaborate with the web performs has up
string as well as the specification
authors to improve this back at the test
suite it is also typical to eventually
expose these interfaces to the global
object but this is no mandatory and
depends on various complex
complexities at this phase the feature
is still in experimental status
depending on the release schedule this
feature may be released to users while
it is experimental and it may get
updated in the release branch with
patches back ported from the master
branch so this is the current status of
webworkers and performance timing API
eventually this feature would be or it
is supposed to be moved out of
experiment and becomes a stable feature
this is the first aiders of the URL and
encoding emulation so here's a quick
summary no crepey eyes have converged
from the web api speaker because they
were designed for very different use
cases but more and more web GIS have now
been added into no core we have worked
through the existing web api seen no
core and their status then we looked
into the challenges and the workflow of
bringing more api's into no court in the
future so finally we are starting in
open standards initiative know to
collaborate more with centers and other
implementations as we have talked about
earlier there are still many open
questions to answer and it takes a lot
of energy to figure out the solutions so
if you are interested please get
involved thank you
[Music]